I I know the divisions like in this
weird turmoil but it's pretty exciting
because you got a bunch of killers
Yuri's Yuri versus Alex such a fun fight
we just need Alex to get past yon if you
just get over that we're going Sizzler
that division is gonna be fun
now Brandon
what is popping fam happy Monday kiddos
Monday morning July 17th how was the
weekend is it hot where you're at
because it's a smooth 105 here in the
valley that Valley weather baby
um yeah man just trying to stay cool in
this heat I feel like a freaking bearded
dragon right now it is Toasty out there
fam hopefully you guys staying cool
um I was at uh Knott's Berry Farm on
Sunday
Wednesday went to Knott's Berry and
anybody in here it's not a popular place
amongst
it's not like a Disney or Disney they
live in OC around that area it's a cool
place to go yeah it's only about it's in
between Long Beach and Huntington it's
about 30 minutes Inland Park yeah not
too bad from here though like 40 minute
drive you want to go to a legit theme
park
um I don't think I posted oh I posted on
the kiddos
but oh dude I crashed at the carnival
games crashed God I crashed it
just I just got all the just all the all
the toys for the kids all this they call
them stuffies I mean just stop this
thing boom you have to get to one above
100 in order to win the biggest prize
dude three times on that thing the
basketball dominate the weird basketball
thing and then the uh
the uh the baseball one look at T just
loaded them up well as we get freaking
superstar that Knott's Berry they should
make it illegal man I just get all the
Stuffies for the kids they can't cost
much those come from straight from China
probably cost them 50 cents
kids were crunk though dude yeah but
yeah uh Knott's Berry
all my uh sons friends parents are
telling us how it's like it's the new
thing like it's they put a lot of money
into it they've read oh they revamped
they re-ramped it because I think
somebody died at one of the things
really yeah one of the the they had like
the water thing that would drop and I
think someone passed away from it they
knocked all that out redid it that dude
they have the best roller coaster I've
been on the ghost town roller coaster
40 year old dies in Plunge at Knott's
Berry Farm so that sounds like the water
idea
you know I think when that happened they
uh kind of revamped it but I don't know
where they put some money into it they
get a nice Jam there boysenberry Jam
they make their own Knott's Berry Jam
free kids out there if you like jam they
got a nice Jam going a little different
than Disneyland but it's uh
it's good for kids it's good it's better
than than the other theme parks because
they got a lot of stuff to do for Boston
they got a lot of rides for them and
then then Tiger's old enough to go on
the roller coasters and that dude that
ghost town Roco is the most legit roller
coaster in California
I don't know what I don't know what Six
Flags got to cooking I don't know what
they got Brewing over there in Santa
Clarita but uh that ghost town roller
coaster legit I want to say Ghost Town
roller coaster is also the one on uh
step by step the intro to step by step I
don't think so is that Six Flags it but
it's in a different like State no that's
California I thought really pretty sure
well that's where they well that's where
the show is supposed to take place right
but it's it's TV right so it's not all
Colossus
Twisted glasses that does look like the
one that's in Valencia Colossus is in
Valencia yeah click on it
that's Six Flags
just say where this one's at
steampunk different no
yeah Valencia yeah you're right you're
right see I think they kind of knocked
it down or something or maybe they just
did another one but you know they still
have it there
step by step day by day great show man
great show
TGIF Fridays the show is lit uh too it
wasn't lit is the card over the weekend
let's get right into it
um
uh it was a it was a down for me across
the board and once my boy attends for
Kenny lost that bummed me out
um I watched the prelims a lot of
decisions a lot of decisions and then
the first kind of stoppage came due to
this girl's arm falling off uh Nunez won
via TKO injury
the way she defended the single leg kind
of caused it but whatever
um outside that you know our boy uh Jack
Della
how to how to fight on his hands got
that newcomer that newcomer is damn good
yeah that's there's so much talent out
in the world now it's different when a
guy takes a short notice fight
especially when he's coming from Brazil
these Brazilian Killers we got these
Russian or dagestanes you cranian or
where the hell they're from these days
good jacket Stan you know they're
problems man
this kid was good
he's gonna be a problem in the UFC
Jack had his hands full some people
thought Jack lost the fight I thought he
won I'm also biased as [__]
I thought he won though but I'm sure
those fight this kid brought it really
showed out definitely deserved another
uh deserves more Egyptian
he's Egyptian I think so you never know
what you're gonna get yeah yeah it's
born in Philly though so he he's
American but American Egyptian damn well
they got his net worth on there like
that 50 Grand come on man you guys don't
know
may have some Investments that's just
what he's worth in the fight game right
now that's gonna get his stock went up
though even though he lost and then
Holly Holm lost via ninja joke second
round
you know Holly's older man
all these all these a lot older so uh
father time she's 41 41 yeah yeah that's
I mean that's old dude for for a fighter
you know so another main event for Holly
Holm so it is what it is man but yeah
the fight card wasn't great uh this
weekend's I assume is gonna be a lot
better because it's in England and
England always shows out whether you
have all the names on the card or just a
mediocre card uh I would say this one's
kind of mediocre even though the
the top billing goes to Tom Asimov who's
back after the injury uh to Curtis
blades
I think Tom aspell has world champion
written all over him you know if I did
bet on a guy in the heavyweight division
be Tom aspinall
the caveat there's you got uh uh homeboy
the Russian Sergey pavlovich who's up I
just I don't know what they're gonna do
with him he's a [__] monster
um but isn't he fighting uh
is he fighting um homeboy
Sergey didn't he find Sarah gondex is
that right let me look that's a fight
that I don't see Cyril gone winning
I don't know who the [__] gonna be
pavlovich see that's April though
it's just after though
he's gonna wait for the winner between
John and Stipe yeah this is old chin
let's see
pretty sure it's uh
yeah see if the if they announce it yet
September
this is from May
I don't know if it's official but looks
like their eyes that's the Rumblings and
that's what they should do
I God I don't see seragano in that fight
I see I see Cyril gone stay on the
outside Landing a bunch of light kicks
and Adventure skin knocked out cold by
our boy the Russian pavlovich he's a
problem uh he's the problem he's the
outlier
the heavyweight division could use a Tom
Asimov who's probably the most athletic
guy not named Sarah gone but as far as
his full game he's better at everything
as far as a package his striking's not
as good as Cerro guns but his MMA skill
set is way better than show guns if that
makes sense Thomas is a freak on the
feet on the ground athletically
um he's probably the best full-rounded
athlete the heavyweight division has he
just doesn't have that key win and he
thought he was gonna get over Curtis
blades we beat Curtis blades be fighting
for a title but uh that Curtis Blaze
obviously just blew his freaking knee
out so now he's back he's facing Tiberia
in his uh in the O2 Arena in London he's
a big favorite for a reason he should
beat tibera pretty easily I don't think
he beats Siberian and gets a title shot
because the
yeah he's a minus 450 at heavyweight
that's massive massively up meatball
doing the damn thing you know she's
gonna win especially in London should
get it done but uh
yeah I I don't think Tom Aslan can beat
uh Tiberia after uh you know this layoff
that he's had up with the knee injury
and then call for a title shot there's
there's gonna be a few more you know I'd
send one or two more if you get stop
shot but hey wait the heavyweight
division is not exactly stacked but also
Stipe John's coming up in November
um I would assume Stipe retires after
that fight in some weird world that we
live in in this MMA Real Housewives of
mixed martial arts if if Stevie were to
beat him then you get a rematch clause
there Steve would do it for the money
that's if he beat him but I assume Jon
Jones takes care of business steepe
retires when the best to ever do it and
then you have John Sergey waiting the
wings
um
Chris blade just lost a pavlovich Tom
asked I would like
yeah so I'd assume yeah it's tough
because Tom wins this one
let's say Tom aswell wins this one Chris
Blade's coming off a loss
stupid retires so everyone bumps up so
you have zero gone Sergey there Sergey
is bringing me the next in line
I mean yeah Tom would need at least one
more win you can't beat Tiberian get a
title shot you just can't I mean we've
seen weirder [__] I assume Tom would
have to get through a cereal gun even if
he lost or a Sergey or even a Curtis
blades even because we didn't get that
fight you'd have to do that to get a
title shot
the Pickens are slim though every
division is weird
with John at the top at the helm there
Sarah Ghana got absolutely destroyed by
Francis
steepe retires Chris blades got starched
by pavlovich
Thomas got in this weird space let's
take a little break from chatting your
ear off because it is time take your
shot at huge wins with my friends at
DraftKings Sportsbook you could win big
with money lines props parlays and so
much more right now new customers can
score 150 in bonus bets instantly for
betting just five dollars on anything
yet UFC fight night this weekend in
London you got asthma big favorite you
got molly the meatball big favorite you
got Paul Craig Jai Herbert you got Davey
Grant there's all sorts of fun bets you
can make and make sure you parlay those
bad boys so you earn extra cash you know
it's got MLB popping it's past All-Star
break so man you got are the Phillies
gonna get ohtani if they do bet money on
them you got my Rockies never bet with
them always bet against my Rockies you
got the the Texas Rangers balling right
now you got
um what else you got my Padres that's my
team to be honest you have apologies
they're not great they've lost two to
Phillies Dodge is always good point is
you got MLB can bet on you got UFC you
can bet on you got all sorts of fun ways
to make money while watching your
favorite sports with my friends at
DraftKings again uh you can score 150 in
bonus bets instantly by betting just
five dollars on any game or fight you
want download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app use code shop show schab show that's
code shop show only at draftking
Sportsbook gambling problem call 100
Gambler in New York call 8778 Hope NY or
text Hope NY 467369 in West Virginia
visit
www.1800 gambler.net and part
partnership with Hollywood Casino at
Charlestown Races all games regulated by
West Virginia Lottery please play
responsibly in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
cccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
Resort Kansas 21 One Plus in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details State specific
responsible gambling resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply terms in Sportsbook Dot
draftkings.com baseball terms if you're
still listening that's download
DraftKings promo code chop show this
episode of the shop show is also brought
to you by my friends that make the best
Kratom on the planet we talk about happy
hippo happy happy hippo if you're
willing to try Kratom you want to go out
in the limb and try creative it's all
the fuss and rage right now if you want
to try create them you can only do it
from a source that you trust I use their
products I ask them to be part of the
show because I use their products I
trust them and you guys can trust them
trust me here it's happy hippo Kratom
they have it all you want to get stuff
done but you want that crazy high from
an energy drink you want that nice
balance Good Feeling Focus feeling
that's why my friends at happy hippo
they got Kratom and they got the shots
for you they got the powders they got
the gummies they got it all they even
have freaking k-dips those are Kratom
dips you know I love my nicotine but
this is not nicotine this is just kratom
in dips called Gay dips Wintergreen
Razzle Zazzle they're fantastic there's
so many ways to get good Kratom now from
happy hippo and save money when you use
the promo code thick23 that's Happy
hippo.com type in promo code thick 23
thick with three C's you get 20 off for
life from the best Kratom on the planet
this Creator is my Hidden Gem it's happy
hypocratum or bust happyhippo.com Bronco
thick23 can't be any weirder than
freaking the light heavyweight division
with uh Jamal Hill going on his YouTube
channel if you haven't watched it it's a
good watch it's a tough watch it's
authentic you can see it's the first
time he kind of comes to terms with him
rupturing his Achilles tending while
playing a UFC basketball Celebrity Game
and he realizes he's out for a hot
second ruptured Achilles is no punk it's
gonna take a hot second good for him for
relinquishing the belt like heavyweight
divisions just
since John left went to heavyweight it's
been a cursed division it's been um you
know it's been Final Destination for the
light heavyweight division they've had
more relinquished titles than they've
had title defenses I think the last
three belts have been relinquished
um and then there's a bunch of injured
guys the top guys you have rakik who's
coming back hopefully you have yiri
who's coming back hopefully Jamal Hill's
out for a hot second racket's been out
for a while Yuri's been out for a hot
second
um obviously want to draw
yeah Johnny Walker in the in the shadows
there
and outside there it gets a little dicey
get super dicey
so I what do you if you have to pick Jen
who's the light heavyweight champion at
the end of this year if Yuri's health so
have they announced that
um Alex Pierre and yon are for the
vacant uh everyone's saying that should
be the case but they didn't announce it
I think Luke Thomas I thought Luke
Thomas tweeted that that's what they
were gonna do
it's not confirmed yet no
because I think the last I heard is both
the Agents of yawn and Alex Pierre said
they haven't been notified yet
officials confirmed young blockowitz
Alex Perry won't be fighting for the
title that's 20 hours ago from sports
key to 20 hours ago so if UFC officials
confirmed I don't get why they wouldn't
do it
let's see this one here this is why not
you see making Yan blockers oh it's a
question mark I know the divisions like
in this weird turmoil but it's pretty
exciting because you got a bunch of
killers Yuri's Yuri versus Alex such a
fun fight
um we just need Alex to get past yawn
it's his Duff's matchup besides uh
Margaret Madoff that there is Monument I
mean by far the toughest match-up form
if you just get over that we're going
Sizzler that division is gonna be fun
because Yuri Alex is fun Johnny Walker
Alex is fun rack cake Alex is fun
let's see
whoa that's weird they said this is a
sponsored ad from the UFC this is bar
owners managers fans are looking for
where to watch UFC 291 on July 29th
boost business expand your customer base
host the event at your bar attract fans
who are more likely to order drinks food
visit during non-event nights with two
title fights the fan demand is ramping
up Dustin Poirier just engage you take
my money Jan versus Alex Pierre says so
it says with two title fights so they
puts yawn and Alex in there so someone
from the UFC leaked that
apparently it makes sense why wouldn't
you do it it adds more eyeballs to the
that paper you see 91
you'll see official tell me this is a
typo That's Mike bone from ma junkie
it's also tough at their weight class to
tell them instead of three it's five if
they're smaller weight class I get it
with them hey fellas I know your biggest
[__] but you're gonna go 25 minutes
that's tough
yeah listen there's no hate on yawn I
love John's great I I just really want
Alex to win
I think Alex can be champ
and the matchups are so fun the light
heavyweight division would be so much
more fun with Alex Pierre's champion
because Alex Pierre wants Jamal Hill
comes back that's fun now in this no
knock on Jamal either I don't think he
was going to offend the title very long
I think that thing rotates a while the
matchups are insane
like Yuri's just great at crazy he's the
best as far as crazy goes he's the
number one guy he's the champ at the
relinquish his belt due to injury
magomat just did beat it dude we can't
have you yeah be your bad for eating
speed it yawn you've had your chance but
you like to rest a little bit you beat
it but if you have racket you have
krylov you got Johnny Walker Anthony
Smith owes the mayor Yuri come on dude
Hill
it's by it's the best of vision f f
Mega Mod just gets out of there
I hate to do it to you beat it beat it
nerd
but outside that God duh you got some
fun matchups get some fun matchups there
man
all right Jim what do you got all right
I can't wait for UC 291 we will have a
Cowboys fight campaign for that for UFC
291 that's two weekends from now July
29th then August 5th you have the
original fight campaigning crew doing a
fight campaign for
um Corey sandhagen's fight and that's on
JRE with Eddie Bravo Brian Callan and
myself oh cool yep that's August 5th in
Austin
that's also the Jake and Nate yep that's
right Santa Hagan versus nuger Madoff
what's the rest of card like let's take
a look
great uh that Jacoby Kennedy fights
really good
Billy uh corintillo it's a good one OSP
Q Libra all right oh Tata Suarez okay
card's kind of tasty
it's not pay-per-view
said [__] Murdock is on there he's
always great
okay all right for fight night it's not
bad
it's in Nashville
you know the bus when the boys and me
front row promoting [__] slap Fight
League or something
shout out to will yeah shout out to him
all right we're talking about Jamal Hill
so one of the things people were saying
was that he was he might have injured
himself as well because he was not in
like Peak condition he was kind of
overweight so if you see this video this
is from June 14th check out his body
real quick
and then it doesn't show so I took the
boys thick it is yeah all right he is
thick so I did like little screenshots
and I added some more exposure so you
see how big he is yeah so at a camp he
gets pretty big yeah but not like a bit
swole like healthy big no no like uh out
of shape yeah the belly starts to get
big yeah he's been celebrating champ
stuff good for him
so you mentioned the arm break so they
but they said he did it during the
basketball game yeah well I mean that's
the rumors but the rumor came from like
Damon Martin who's a very trusted Source
yeah if they say and then also Annex
said it this morning I'm pretty sure
because that's the only that's where it
happened that's not like some weird
conspiracy that's where it happened
another DC and everybody saw it so
definitely happened there
um
yeah it's just a it's a tough time the
light heavyweight Division and that
sucks for Jamal Hill man you're just
about to start making money like real
money yeah they take it from me you can
see he was pretty choked up about oh
yeah he was like I think he was crying
he's emotional hell yeah I cry yeah
so this is the armbreaker talking about
by estela Nunes she got taken down you
can see it here
it completely hyper extends and then
Dana White posted this that's her x-ray
MRI and then the elbow completely went
out of its socket but then it's back in
place now well that's best case yeah
broken yeah that's weird to say people
say it broke it didn't break I mean
because it went yeah it didn't break
though
yeah just out of soccer that's the best
case for her I mean the ligaments do we
know she tore ligaments or anything I
don't know
bless you and this one you know I was
thinking about this one my girl's
sneezed she's like you didn't say bless
you I'm like ah I don't like that
since I was a kid so you don't like it
when people say it to you or you don't
like I like any of it I like it I like
it I like it my dad says consume tight
oh my gosh what does that even come from
German it's German
for Club God bless you yeah Gesundheit
excuse me are you German oh you're not
don't say that my dad gets in town this
week I'll sneeze kazoo please don't do
that yeah God bless you interesting
means health
oh yeah for the Jets
[Music]
for the jet he's a stud to the detached
over the Jets he's doing everything
bless you thank you
like joke
thank you
um so this was funny is the girl running
yeah it's funny because the way that uh
Daniel Cormier and and this the panel
were just laughing because it was
they've never seen something like this
before so this is Chelsea Chandler
running away from Norma Dumont after she
she got hit with some combos
[Music]
like oh hell no
it's sprinting
[Laughter]
he said that's got my mom chasing me
with a belt ODC said if she if the of
the cage door is open she just kept
talking
was it DC
yeah if the kids doors open right shut
the [__]
that was so funny but the girl took it
in striped yeah she posted a thing going
uh the moment I realized I [__] this
is the moment where I realized [__] up
yeah and she said she was running
initially she said she was running to
her corner to hear her coaches but she
was looking it up so oh yeah this is
funny yeah Michael Bisping said on his
podcast that he heard that the the the
purse for Francis and Ghana was going to
be around 30 million Jake Paul someone
said it's gonna be like uh 8 million but
then Jake Paul reiterated that it's
going to be eight figures eight figures
yeah here's the thing guys and this
happens in politics and all this fake
news when you know Francis is going
against the game here he's he's he's
he's an outlier so what he's doing they
don't want other fighters to mimic
because it's not good for the overall
business of the suits so you're gonna
get a lot of fake news that's
orchestrated by people in the business
that try to make Francis look bad no
matter what so when this came out like 8
million they see obviously the Dana nut
suckers jump on like eight million do
you see offered him eight million what a
dumbass that's all planned all that's
planned to make Francis look stupid and
no it wasn't a smart decision he made a
mistake when you go Against the Machine
the machine comes for you and that's
what happens with this stuff and then
people just paired it and I get it you
know me I'm right or die for UFC but you
got to be careful man because what
Francis is doing is is beating the
system and whenever that happens people
will try to sabotage that
um you know it's like you know with
Francis too remember the thing came out
and I went over this with count on
firing the kid when it came out oh it's
an exhibition fights not real they got
the deal done but right away what came
out X but not a real boxing match it's
already that suppresses what's going on
oh man it's a gimmick this is [__]
so that suppresses that and people just
they don't look into it they don't read
headlines they don't actually all they
do is read headlines they don't actually
look take the time to see what's really
going on well who said that Eddie heard
why did he leaked that out well he has
this is his competition he lost the
fight he couldn't get this stuff done so
and he couldn't get a fight down with
Francis and his guy so then he's gonna
make this look bad also Eddie Hearns and
Cahoots with Dana well you know what you
know you you think Dana wants France
look good no no so what can we do to
make to try and ruin this thing to try
and just make it look bad and the fan
base picks up on it eight dude eight
million what a dumb ass right so it's
just their way of sabotaging Francis
don't believe it friends when I saw
eight million like you guys are
hilarious France making way more money
than that way more
and it's this weird narrative too I I
let's again I you know I bleed UFC but
you guys man Francis won he made the
right choice let it go be happy for the
guy who so one guy got out so you got
one Andy to frame got out all good dude
we don't need to [__] on him okay
because at first is what a dumb ass
fighting siding with pfl he'll never get
the Tyson Fury fight my whole stance on
that is yeah if he's just fighting pfl
even though they're giving him
everything he wanted the gate major 50
of the pay-per-view whatever it is
there's no names there if that was just
the case he just signed pfl yeah I agree
with you guys probably not the smartest
Choice probably should stay in the UFC
caveat there is none of this MMA stuff
matters if he lands a Tyson Fury fight
or Deontay Wilder fight or Anthony
Joshua fight it's all him leaving it was
all predicated on that I've always said
that none of this MMA stuff matters as
long as he gets the Tyson Fury fight in
the bag [__] everything forget MMA
whatever whatever happens in pfl I don't
care he fights guy we've never heard of
doesn't matter he makes more money than
he would ever make in a 10-year UFC pfl
career in one night no matter Win Lose
or Draw how he does against Tyson Fury
that is the sign that he won he got that
Francis is one no matter how you feel
about it what do you think of the fight
if you just think it's a exhibition
because you're a dumbass all good
Francis won
hands down Francis one be careful
because the machine's coming for him
they're trying to suppress everything
he's doing it's all good guys Francis
one made the right choice so now it was
France never again the fury fight [__]
up fighting the the pfl okay
Francis schizophary fight fight gets
announced you have his exhibition we
know it's not but he's making eight
million now he's making way more than
that okay but still that's stupid what's
he gonna do in the pfl all right so it's
just they keep moving the post well
Francis messed up but he achieves that
well okay he got that but Prince messed
up he achieves that okay but Francis
yeah you got those two but this just be
happy for the guy what do you care man
don't you want to see a guy succeed I
don't get it I don't get the hate on it
just because he left the UFC and he won
which no one's ever really done not at
this level
but I'm I'm just warning this won't be
the first time they do this exhibition
not true eight million not true what's
next get ready for it get ready for it
it's like a CNN or Fox they just push
all this fake [__] at you and then
eventually like oh that fight's just
[__] look into it don't be a sheep
good for Francis definitely if it's 30
mil that's incredible
uh so Daniel I'd say it's somewhere
around three mirror that's remember it's
it's in uh Saudi Arabia yeah I'm not
sure if you guys notice they have all
the all the money
literally all them they all the richest
people in the world are in the Middle
East they're not in Forbes top 100
because they pay not to be on they don't
want you know how they have unlimited
amount of money
Francis fighting Saudi Arabia it could
not be any better for he's making all
the money
all the money be happy for the day of
course a little break oh kiddos this
episode of the shop show is brought to
you by my friends at on it on it has the
best nootropic on the planet you guys
know this talking about Alpha Brain the
silver million bottles I like the black
label because the highly concentrated
Alpha Brain but they have Alpha Brain
instant the Alpha Brain ready shot they
got it all for you you get your money
back guaranteed if you don't love it but
you're gonna love it so don't worry
about that uh Alpha Brain the best
nootropic on the planet helps in mental
processing it's caffeine free helps with
the flow State promotes Focus supports
memory they got it all can also save on
their best award-winning supplements
we're talking about protein powders
Warrior bars creatine fish oils
multivitamins we got it all workout uh
kettlebells Club maces streaming Fitness
anna.com shop temp shop everything all
your fitness goals it's a thick Boy
Summer but not that thick let audit help
you it's audit.com shop 10 off let's get
back to the program uh so Daniel Cormier
was pretty local like he's a vocal
critic of Francis leaving the ufcs like
you're gonna get opportunities like this
so after this happened he's like
I want to Fumble the bag too he
completely did a 180 so that's that was
pretty cool of him but also again I love
DC who's DC work for of course he has to
do something you think he's gonna go on
his DC and uh Ryan Clark an RC show and
say France made the right decision no
you know you're working for Mickey Mouse
and I love DC uh Brian Clark's my boy I
love Ryan Kirk That's my boy but you
can't expect a hot take on there when a
guy goes against UFC and wins for him to
be like yeah good for him man you know
on ESPN on his podcast to say it you
know be careful
when I worked for Showtime I'd pitch you
guys on Bellator I had to be the face of
defend McGregor like you that's a paid
gig man they pay you well I get it
it's not selling out just doing your job
yeah it's insane I like it
so this uh this fight between Fury and
Francis it's not going to be for the
belt which we all pretty much knew right
but it will go on as official record on
their official record yes Pro fight
belts are all hearsay who gives a [__]
that this could be for whatever belt you
want belts I do not care about when it
comes to this stuff especially this type
of stuff when a guy's from UFC MMA this
guy's from boxing we I don't need a belt
let's say Fury knocks him out let's say
Tyson knocks him out
or let's say Francis knocks out Fury you
guys know who won what do you give a
[__] if he has a gold trap around his
shoulder with this stuff who cares but
again this is another way to knock this
down yeah it goes on their boxing record
which makes it a legit as [__] fight it
means that it's not an exhibition so you
have that there it's not an exhibition
this is a real 10 round [__] fight in
Saudi Arabia on August 28th I'm sorry
October 28th legit as [__]
so knock the exhibition down all right
what else you got yeah but it's a real
fight but there's no belts so it doesn't
count
get hits keep coming the hits keep
coming so this was from MMA junkie I
heard people saying it's gonna be 12
round but I made junkie that's the most
the most recent report I saw was going
to be a 10 round heavyweight boxing
match yeah so you know you can't be an
exhibition you know 10 Rounds makes it
legit 12 rounds makes it super legit it
feels like foreign but
now who does who does more pay-per-views
we got a lot of pushback when I said
there's only one fight the UFC could
make that would beat Fury versus Francis
it was Zuckerberg versus Elon people got
upset like you think Fury and Francis
does more pay-per-views than steepe and
John
yeah
wait there's a lot of push-up on in okay
well of course Elon and yeah of course
that's that and that's why I said that
that's a no-brainer but Stipe John
versus the steepe John with the
marketing of the UFC do more
pay-per-views than Francis Fury
no
Stephen John does it no he doesn't I
don't think it does I mean I we don't
know for a fact but if I'm gonna know
nobody knows but let's talk about it but
I mean yeah people in boxing want to see
this even though they I heard people in
boxes don't like the factors they always
say that but they're going to watch them
these [__] buy it and people and
mayor want to see this so I'm like two
big you know two big fan bases gonna be
watching all right let's play Devil's
Advocate there look at France's biggest
pay-per-view bring up France
pay-per-views he's never been a big
pay-per-view star that's one of the
reasons UFC let him walk
so it says 500 000 to say five hundred
thousand yeah
estimate uh-huh
and that's that's steep a one or two
distribute one
oh no there's two and that would
probably be his biggest one right I
would imagine
oh click on that uh Reddit next time you
next time you goofy folks when the guy
was a paper remember the same opponent
Sam Belt Jones sold at least double the
pay-per-views
so that's against zero gone so you have
so his last fight did 300 pay-per-view
bites
Jones and that's obviously because of
the Dana did this but Jones for whatever
reason got labeled as can't sell
pay-per-views that's not true in any
facet he always does he doesn't do like
Conor numbers or Brock but they're
always super solid like big time solid
did 300 000 pay per device
and then steep A2 did 500 000.
point of all this is is Francis has
never been a huge pay-per-view star yeah
it takes a while to get really big as a
paper you start think how long John's
been [__] fighting see uh his uh the
Kane versing got on UFC on ESPN probably
got a ton of views but that was on ESPN
dos Santos ESPN so rosenstruke that you
don't need to bring that up that didn't
do well Steve a pay-per-view Sarah God
pay-per-view
let me look at his UFC 220
220 yeah
against uh steep A1 350 000. like not
gangbuster numbers not bad but you
wouldn't label them as a pay-per-view
star so
is francis's
star bigger now than it was
when he when he beat cerrogan
he was in the headlines a lot then it
started going away a little bit now it's
been now it's back so I don't know
point but my only point there is he's
never been a major pay-per-view outlier
so he's gonna be one now but people that
are saying that right now like they know
what's gonna happen none of us know
what's gonna happen no that's why I'm
gonna tune in yeah so but this is this
would be predicated on people that maybe
didn't buy a Francis fight that are fans
of the UFC now the Intrigue is let's see
what
let's see what happens when they went by
like a Cyril God Francis or Stipe
Francis now they're just overall curious
what's gonna happen so you can assume
he's bringing probably five to six
hundred thousand buys himself Fury is a
beast yeah bring up Furious pay-per-view
numbers now pay-per-view
across the ponds a little different
but he brings numbers
that's the draw here
so just these two right here Fury Wilder
2 was 800 000 Fury Wilder 3 was 600 000
in us and around 300 000 overseas
yeah they're massive pay-per-views
let's see this one here Derek chisora
to see the but uh tresoras they're big
overseas yeah
300 000 with chisora okay not great but
that's just Sora
I know but my point is it's like
yeah you're when the carnivorous anybody
does gangbuster numbers Rhonda versus
anybody does gangbuster Brock does gang
best it doesn't matter who that is fear
hsr3 made more than 500 000.
well we'll see and plus this will go
down the Furious top selling
pay-per-views on your last article yeah
you were just there I know
yeah click on that
you're saying Klitschko 1.7
1.2 million Wilder one
yeah but see they combined the US and
the UK it's not what they do with the
UFC numbers too though I imagine they
would just do all the sales
so if yeah fear is a big draw so he's
definitely the a side here yeah and I I
would assume it does a mill
I mean I would assume too and plus this
is the first time it's ever been like a
real like lineal Champions right he's
he's a champion he's boxing and Francis
gonna do he was Champion yeah this is
the first time you have like a guy who's
on this side greatest knockout artist in
the UFC who was Champion left fighting
The pound-for-pound Undefeated best
boxing world they're both heavyweights
yeah and they can it's different than
like a uh McGregor Floyd even though
both those guys are way more famous this
is more competitive I would and you know
theirs did massive pay-per-view numbers
but it's Connor and Floyd yeah no yeah I
I I assume if this doesn't do a million
it's a failure I would I mean you would
assume it does too right two mil I say a
mill
guaranteed yeah maybe 1.5 at most I
think I don't know about two mil you
don't think two million I think he does
two mil
I think too yeah now we're looking at
the numbers anything about Floyd and
Conor did even though you had the UFC
machine behind that
yeah France isn't the best at talking
ship you don't need him it's kind of
like a drago versus Rocky type of thing
just the gypsies the American Rocky in
this
I don't really oh
McGregor Mayweather's 2.4
what
so Pacquiao me where this is 4.6 Buy
rate yep and then McGregor Mayweather
says Four Points have you talked to kill
Soden he says Mayweather pack out even
close to that neither did Mayweather
McGregor because there's also no way to
check these like I don't know how this
is even but listen those are the biggest
pay-per-views no matter even the numbers
cut in half whatever
yeah you would assume it does two mil
right
you guys do you think it does a mill I
think a 1.5 is a good number
no definitely potential tell Georgie to
put up a poll does Francis vs Fury
uh over under 2 million buys
good
what else you got Jen I think it should
hit if it doesn't do a million this
thing was a complete waste if it does
like 400 000 which I don't know dude
that would be hard even that's a good
number for like a fight that's just
awful for that in the much of Saudi
Arabia's pain now grant them give a
flying [__] about money out there
because they have so much money coming
out their anuses they don't give a [__]
yeah it'd be fun to see what happens I'm
with case on this I think he does
between I'll say between 1.6 and 2
million that'd be great if it does yeah
and Francis gets 1.6 and he pay for you
growing Sizzler he's already going to
Sizzler too and now chair was saying
that Fury is a piece of [__] and his
scumbag for taking this fight you know
it's He's a Bully hey jail no Francis is
winning dude even if he gets knocked
down the first round the amount of money
he gave me this amazing also if I'm if
I'm fury it's like hold on hold on so I
can fight usick I know the Box more
wants to it I can fight who's a tough
[__] night in the office or I can
make probably more money fighting France
a guy he's not a boxer and it's a
massive fight and he looks scary why
don't I do both why don't I go fight
Francis the new sick doesn't go anywhere
because I'm the a side so if all I care
about is money my legacy I'm gonna take
out the scariest Guy come out of the UFC
I'm gonna take him out and then I'll
jump over and take out usick and then
right after the sunset
like I don't care if box are not a boxer
that shot that shot lands on anybody I
don't care who you are yeah that's why
this fight is more intriguing than
Connor versus Floyd
way more intriguing because Connor he's
still a small dude man he doesn't have
that one shot knockout power the best
defensive box of all time even he landed
uppercut Francis lands out uppercut this
thing's over that's why it does two
million miles yeah and also I was your
point uh Alistair was basically the best
striker in heavyweight hands down right
yeah no worse accomplished no argument
yeah
but there were kicks too but you know
hey all right so this is pretty cool
depending on who you are but Jake Paul
landed the cover of Sports Illustrated
and him and Dana what are the fat girls
they put on Sports Illustrated now
uh so he was pretty low he said people
are gonna hate on it for sure but he's
like hey of course but that's Jake Paul
anything does the hate on Welcome to the
party Jake because he's so brand new to
boxing yeah but it's dope what he's
doing for boxing he deserves to be on
the cover
who else you're gonna put on we can put
on Francis
what France is doing is more
groundbreaking than anything right now
yeah it's never been done right
um
so this is apparently leaked footage of
Nate Diaz Diaz sparring a 30 and one pro
boxer and this is like a month ago so I
wanted you to see how his spine looks
which one's Nate in Black he's the one
with the white shirt I believe okay let
me double check
yeah white shirt
oh
[Music]
this guy's 3-1 and Nature's walking him
down
[Music]
pause it I've seen enough yeah he looks
good A lot of people he looks so slow I
saw this comments he slows molasses
whatever here's the other thing we don't
know what round that is what's what part
of sparring that is we don't know if
he's been in there with six fresh bodies
and this guy jumps in we don't know if
this is the eighth sparring round we
don't know if this is the 12th sparring
round we don't know
either way I don't even know he looks
pretty [__] good Jake if he's taking
that guy's 30-1 so
um and he's walking for he's walking him
down which can be a problem for Jake
without pressure like I'm I'm telling
you man if if Nate respects Jake like
you think he will if he respects him and
takes it serious Jake could be in some
trouble man
the problem is Jake Just Hits hard as
[__] and he's quick early on but is that
the longer that fight goes the better
for Nate
and Nate's durability is like insane so
yeah it's gonna be cool to watch that
fight so but but online people are
hating on Nate right like you look so
slum like I didn't see that here I see a
a Nate put in some work against the 31
guy also Landing some great body work
went to the head and just walking him
down a goddamn Terminator if you're a
jake fan you should be alarmed by this
indeed so this sucks Walt Harris who's
been through you know that crazy thing
where his daughter was horrible yeah so
he had to get he was supposed to fight
on this last card but then he got popped
by usada and he says it was something
that he's
a supplement he's been using for a long
time he never got it checked which is he
feels stupid about but it'll get cleared
away soon and he'll get back to finding
but he did get popped by asada yeah they
pulled him right yeah
all good [__] happens
yeah
you saw the only catches guys like this
though
didn't the last big person he saw this
got
very suspect yeah
um I'm not gonna go too much into this
one but just the whole the the deal with
uh jail signing in the hotel thing it's
over now yeah I talked to the channel
over the weekend cool good for him yeah
it's a relief
I hope Chao tells the full story
there's a reason I defended him
I hear you so the ESPYs happened and Jon
Jones won UFC fighter of the year
I thought Jamal Murray should win it too
right because I know Jamal Jamal Murray
won come back shout to the Nuggets my
boy Jamal Murray uh really I worked you
go to Joe kids because he makes your mom
like whatever Jamal Murray hit some big
shots he's Canadian we forgive him but
he um he wouldn't come back uh come back
athlete athlete of the year Jon Jones
when uh comeback UFC fighter of the Year
best UFC fighter oh best UFC interesting
fighter oh over uh volkanovsky yeah
best comeback yeah the easiest match of
your career choked you out in 30 seconds
looked at a heavyweight okay wait hold
up okay I like it it was actually just
Leon Edwards is on makachev and Amanda
Nunes
I wonder if it's I don't know I don't
know why he lost to makachev
that's stupid
yeah you could I could see it man I
don't know how you give John that the
best you who is it fan votes how does
ESPYs work I don't know I don't know oh
boy Pat McAfee crush it hosting it
though so see Kevin Hart and he didn't
do it because the writers strike
she's you know standing with the writers
who write for the ESPYs yeah it's fans
awards were chosen clearly they didn't
open the phone to Russia
it's Mark Jeff would have won that [__]
I mean I get it what John did you know
sitting out and then jumping in
heavyweight champ but I don't know
I don't know some it doesn't I don't
like it some doesn't fit right some
doesn't sit right with me give that over
mocktail what the guy's mocktails beat
yeah and then I still think wilkonovski
won that fight but I think Broken Eyes
should have won best UFC fighter of the
year
um
comeback athlete Jamal Murray should
definitely get it sat out and he's like
he's a superstar in the playoffs
you know
all right so this one is just uh report
that you know a lot of people are saying
it including here that there's rumors of
Ronda Rousey returning
so I'm telling you from a legit source
well there you go but apparently
according to Ariel helwani said that uh
she's not considering a comeback that's
what he's told and he goes you're not
considering he used to come back told no
truce the rumors started today or
yesterday I heard otherwise I'm not
journalist
I don't do any Source checking I hear
from a legit source
let's see what happens who knows yeah
who knows who knows
um be fun if she did is all I'm saying
so normally we wouldn't cover this but
this is on every like big MMA media
website oh the hot girl showed her tits
and kissed the other girl yes so this is
the kiss first of all this is like
before the fight happened
so you gotta do it properly and then she
was actually going in for a real kiss
and this this girl Amber O'Donnell uh
she's a I don't know the other ones Okay
Whitney Johns I found out later so she's
an only fans person but she's also um
wait I'm not sure she's only with that
but she's Chris camosie's girl yeah
shout out to Chris camozey doing well
huh and then this is Amber yeah she's
the only fan girl thinks I don't know no
she is I know one of them there's
definitely some only fans she's only
fans for sure
and then this is she's cool
Whitney Jones yeah
yeah she's doing all right she's doing
all right and then yeah so she the other
girl which is this one for sure is an
only fans model the Daniella Hensley she
flashed her boobs during this Kingpin
boxing event and then of course Eddie
Hearn was like this is terrible for
boxing yeah it's not great there's a
lane for it good but the real box fans
probably tuned into this but
yeah but apparently according to him
even it says it does great numbers and
it's entertainment but it's not you know
obviously it's nothing comp like close
to but yeah it's different you don't
think people realize that
um
let's go here real quick so George St
Pierre announced that's like last week
or so that he's gonna do it a jiu-jitsu
tournament for the UFC Fight Pass
International or Invitational and he
said the one guy he will not go against
is Gordon Ryan yeah right [__] a time of
nuts but he's looking to do something
with maybe
um
was it Diaz Bros yeah Nate Anderson
Connor which I don't Carlos Condit dami
Maya or khabib you know people that are
in MMA that were good on ground and
khabib would be [__] off khabib would
be awesome
my votes khabib number one and then
Anderson Silva because we didn't we
never got the interesting GSP fight
do you think Damien would still take
GSP yes
uh this I thought was interesting this
is Ian Gary because he's gonna fight
Jeff Neal
and then he made this shirt because Jeff
Neal we talked about it way back he was
uh he got arrested for a DUI DWI
I know there's such Savages I'll just
play this for you
it's your guy's idea I just fall in love
with a nice three I mean that's genius
that one I like that song I like this no
bigger and I'd love to have a little bit
of writing outside of the photo as well
is this girl I know it's funny as [__]
you in yeah you win yeah good to see you
guys again
it's [__] awesome oh my dear Jesus
Christ here
wait I just dropped him as [__] he's
gonna hate us we're at the shoe store
and later we're talking about there has
to be something I can call it blood or
something and then Harrison goes what
let me do is mugshots
let's do it
time finished probably that's awesome
for a DUI a mug shot of Jeff Neal and
then it says the future which is Ian
Gary's interesting yeah I mean Gary's a
fit and then dude I think Jeff Neal
responded like that's just that's going
way too far but it builds up the fight
these kids are savages these yeah that's
so funny that stuff you didn't touch in
my day we just didn't you didn't touch
that stuff but these kids man nothing's
you know off limits
and I I looked into it to see what he
was arrested for obviously when I saw
this so I'm sure a lot of people are
doing the same thing but apparently he
was you know DWI obviously it was like
Thanksgiving he drank and then he had a
gun in his car but then he got a gun
charge as well because if you get pulled
over and you're doing something like in
Texas in Texas so if you're already if
you're committed of or you're charged
with a crime and you have a gun even
though it's licensed it's your gun you
still get charged for that too he's
moved on from it and then yeah now we're
pronounce it back up poor [__] sucks
Neil uh okay so triller remember when
Holyfield fought Belfort and Trump was
there yes guess how much they paid Trump
if you take a while
[__] very close how much 2.5 yeah
just to do that little gig you think how
many people tuned in
it's Donald Trump more people tuning in
to hear Donald Trump talked than
Holyfield fight that's why they did it
very sad
uh so Dan hooker remember he broke his
wrist bro I saw this picture on
Instagram dude whoever did his surgery
is the same doctor did mine it looks
like earthworms there's better surgeons
out there that looks so crazy I know
it's horrible work
I don't like it man mine was like you
can't even see anything it's just it's
just bald but they did it really well no
yeah but no it doesn't go stick out
though you know yeah it's not all bumpy
like he has a giant centipede on his arm
now yeah so I'm glad I got them there's
better work than that dude I don't know
who did that
all right here's a quick one
this is uh somewhere in New York I
believe this is MMA fight and this guy
got a DQ because his cup kept falling
out
it was because he has a big dick though
no he's just like just bad placement of
the cup or just wrong size
the white guy or black guy a black guy
right you see a big old thing and he's
the black guy's doing pretty good too
until it see it fell down
and then he puts it in himself right
there
[Applause]
he probably does he probably just has
regular tights and then just put the cup
in there
why not just fight without a cop dude I
think it's illegal right you can get
away with it like you can fake it like
this it falls out again
he is DQ yep
dq'd for having a giant dick
and then people are blaming the fighter
but then
the in this uh be Harry Mack is saying
that it's probably his manager that
messed up getting the cup fitting or
something I don't know
it takes some accountability dude I
don't know she has that big dick so cups
I thought they would had a strap it
would actually go down sometimes you can
buy like the com the compression shorts
and it has the cup socket in there and
you slide it in here I bet he just had
tights on I was like yeah he's put on
it's gonna stay you know just [__] up
yeah
that stuff has this big old Panther tail
that can't he's pushing it yeah it's
like pushing it out like get it out of
here can't contain that thing so Wanda
Lee Silva is going to return to fighting
he's going to be boxing in November
against a bodybuilder
pretty famous bodybuilder I think in
Brazil that's him right there he's
jacked super jacked and he has like Miss
usada running 4.7 I highly doubt
anyone's gonna be testing yeah nor
should they do you remember Philip
defreeze UFC oh yeah it's a great
submission guy I didn't know this but
he's been killing it in ksw he just
recently got a submission choke on this
beat somebody else too I think he beat
my boy uh McSweeney recently too yeah I
think so too yeah yeah filter freeze is
choking [__] out and do you remember
how he used to look he used to look like
this like a little baby face kind of
dude yeah but now
hold on a sec
this is like your average Joe
damn that shaved the head shaved head
he's giant just tapping [__] is it good
for him Resurgence in the career man
yeah
and this thing sucks okay there he is
he's a big man now yeah I got a bunch of
tattoos put on some weight good for him
and he's like eight or nine and no or as
far as defensing UFC signs them now they
need the help
that stuff well I mean hopefully he's
not on it's awesome who cares
and here's the last one just a quick one
uh I guess the pound for pound rankings
are they change now
folks number one so Volk and John I
guess they do this now tied they put a t
they're both pound for pound which makes
not much sense yeah all those pound for
pounding Up For Debate that's cool
though
yep that's it brother that's it all
right guys thanks for watching uh enjoy
the fights in London O2 Arena the Savior
for London MMA
your boy Tom ask when I was fighting
this weekend uh
you guys know who he is I don't have to
fill you into him Molly the meatballs
fighting got Paul Craig Paul Craig doing
the damn thing Jai Herbert uh Murphy's
fighting David Grant Danny Roberts
um it's a fun card it's England so you
know it's gonna be lit so worth a watch
that goes down Saturday I think noon our
time right PST I'll be tuning in
um outside that few housekeeping notes
for you we just add a bunch more dates
to the tour did you have fun did you
have fun though right did you have fun
uh shopping friends is at the Ice House
July 28th we'll have a killer lineup
with some special guests once you're
only at 8pm I think it's a Saturday
night July 28th uh yeah because the 29th
is a UFC so July 28th a Friday night
um shopping friends the Pasadena ice
house one show only and then official
tour starts in August 11th in Phoenix
one show I'm sorry one night only two
shows that stand up live in Phoenix
Arizona come get some Phoenix then I'm
in Omaha Nebraska August 16th that's a
Wednesday night August 16th Omaha
Nebraska Kansas City Missouri's August
17th that's a Thursday then Liberty
Township Ohio August 30th Columbus Ohio
August 31st Spokane Washington September
21st to the 23rd we had a bunch of other
dates coming out too we had a bunch of
announcements coming out so stay tuned
for on my Instagram Twitter all that
other Shenanigans All Right tickets at
thickboy.com but Phoenix Europe first
August 11th see you guys soon then Omaha
Kansas City all right love you guys be
nice each other stay cool out there
kiddos see you next week